government is facing opposition for
controversial proposed changes to gender
laws the transgender community wants to
simplify the transitioning process but
hardline feminists claim it's an attack
on women's rights will hate to talk
about their experiences award-winning
trans writer and member of the LGBTQ
Advisory Board of the Labour Party Jake
Graff and Britain's highest-ranking
transgender soldier Hannah Winterbourne
great see both hi how are you I'm very
well thank you
it's very interesting all of this and I
want to start really by just getting you
both to tell me your individual stories
Jake perhaps you can talk first about
your experience over the last few years
I mean I knew from a very very young age
on you from about 3:00 that I was male
and I was very vocal about that from
pretty much that age and when it came to
transition I just decided I didn't
really know any other trans people so I
don't know one sort of looked too but I
just did the route that I was told by my
doctors which was you know you
transition you do the medical medically
transition top surgery hormones and then
once you've done all that you apply for
your gender recognition certificate so I
did that and then after you know shortly
after I was obviously able to change my
birth certificate
however Hannah had a slightly different
experience yeah my experience I was
coming up I didn't quite know who I was
and I was different I don't know what
that meant to me and then as I grew
older I realized that I was transgender
and like Jake Jake I embarked on my
transition which is as much as about
kind of your person interactions with
the world as it is the medical side of
life and then I chose not to have a
gender recognition certificate because I
think the process is early bureaucratic
and demeaning okay and you met each
other and found love and that's great
and Jake for people who don't
necessarily understand what these
proposals are just that just in very
basic terms explain what the changes are
and what your what your hopes are that
some don't agree with I mean really all
this change is about is being able to
change our birth certificate without
having to send off paperwork and present
ourselves to a faceless Board of
individuals none of whom will be
transgender and basically say you know
am i man enough to have that birth
difficut changed because it is it's
dehumanizing it's overly bureaucratic
and no one else in the world has - well
certainly not
UK has to say would you please tell me
that I'm a lesbian or please confirm
that I'm a gay man or please confirm
that I'm straight and yet for some
reason for the trans community was still
in that position where we have to be
confirmed and stamped before we can go
on and live our lives so that's what
happens now is that you if you want this
to happen you have to go and speak to a
board of people so if I want to change
my birth certificate now I have to pay
some money I have to provide evidence
that I've become a woman and then that
evidence gets put in front of a panel of
people who I've never met I never get to
see and they decide if I'm woman enough
to be a woman and over what to no
definition of womanhood I'm not quite
sure because you know it was a
definition of womanhood is very very
different you know and then if I fail to
get that process I don't you have a
right of appeal so it's a it's a it's an
overly bureaucratic and extremely
dehumanizing process all on based on
what is someone's definition of what a
woman or a man is okay so it would
appear that that's very reasonable what
you want why is it some people are so
against this change I think that it's
become all a bit muddied a lot of there
are feminists not all for it and there
are some certain people small sections
of the community that believe that it
will mean that all of some trans women
and trans people are in their spaces or
in their changements or in their toilets
that is not the case I mean that has
been the case since 2010 I think so for
the last eight years because of the
Equality Act we have been in those
spaces without incident without problem
and I think it's important to remember
that all this will change really in the
grand scheme of things is our right to
have this birth certificate amended I
mean other than that this that's passed
that's it and bearing in mind that this
right to self-determination which is
what it is a right to self-determine at
I'm a man and Henry's a woman is already
in place in Ireland Portugal Argentina
where else was it Denmark
Malta and it's all working very well
there as it would here and it's a shame
because it just means that the UK is now
slipping behind in those in those human
rights where we always used to set the
benchmark and just briefly transgender
issues seem to be much more in the
mainstream now we talk quite a lot on
this show about the issues that you guys
face I mean how's life now Hannah how do
you find day-to-day life is it well
there's no life for me is just normal
now you know I I don't go around you
know
a transplant wherever I go I am just
myself and that's what this whole you
know policy change is looking to doing
is just giving us the ability to be
ourselves openly and freely and free of
discrimination and now you I can
understand what people have concerns
because they are there are people who
are using this reform as a vehicle to
spread bigotry and hate and you're
hearing lots of arguments from people
saying that you know this is against
women's rights or it's somehow affecting
women it's not this is simply allowing
everyone whoever they are male female
transgender not transgender to be
themselves openly and free of
discrimination and that's all this is
doing seems pretty reasonable to me
Jake Hanna thank you very much indeed
for explaining else at all to us that
preciate your time thank you thanks so
much